75% EFFECTIVE AND SUPPLIES WILL
BE AVAILABLE STARTING AS EARLY
AS 2021.
>> Bret: A VACCINE THAT WORKS
CANNOT COME FAST ENOUGH FOR
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN LOCATION
SLOWING DOWN THE REOPENING
PROCESS.
CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT CHAD
PERGRAM LOOKS AT THE ECONOMIC
CONCERNS AND WHAT CONGRESS MAY
OR MAY NOT DO ABOUT IT.
>> STARK WORDS ON CAPITOL HILL
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
>> REVERSAL OF ECONOMIC FORTUNE
HAS CAUSED A LEVEL OF PAINT
THAT’S HARD TO CAPTURE INWARD.
GREAT UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
>> DIRE PRODUCTIONS FROM
LAWMAKERS.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE
WITHOUT INTERVENTION A WAVE OF
FORECLOSURES AND DEFAULTS.
>> ALL OF THE JOB GAINS OF THE
PAST DECADE HAVE BEEN WIPED OUT.
>> CONGRESS TAKES A TWO WEEK
BREAK ON THURSDAY WITHOUT
APPROVING ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS
BILL.
>> WE JUST CAN’T WAIT FOR OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO WAKE UP
TO THE REALITY IN THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR HOMES,
PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING FED, PEOPLE
ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL WON’T COMMIT TO
ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS BILL.
THE ONLY THING McCONNELL IS
PUSHING, LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM SUING IF
THEY GET SICK AT WORK OR SCHOOL.
>> THESE ARE THE KINDS OF SMART
SOLUTIONS WASHINGTON MUST
CONTINUE DISCUSSING AS WE
EVALUATE WHAT FURTHER STEPS MAY
BE NECESSARY.
>> TODAY IS THE DEADLINE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO APPLY FOR
LOANS UNDER THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
TREASURY SECRETARY STEVEN
MNUCHIN TOLD A HOUSE HEALING HEA
THERE WAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
REPURPOSED THING THE FUNDS
REMAINING BUT THAT REQUIRES
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION AND THERE
IS NO CONSENSUS ON EXTENDING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
YOU CAN ROLL THE DICE AGAIN AT
CASINOS IN MARYLAND BUT THE NEON
LIGHTS ON BROADWAY ARE DARK
UNTIL AT LEAST JANUARY.
AND QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT THE
VIABILITY OF PRO SPORTS.
>> I NEVER SAID WE CAN’T PLAY A
CERTAIN SPORT.
I AM COMPLETELY UNQUALIFIED TO
TELL YOU WHETHER YOU CAN PLAY A
SPORT OR NOT.
>> EXPERTS SAY TRUST IS THE KEY
TO REOPENING.
>> THE PATH FORWARD FOR THE
ECONOMY REMAINS EXTRAORDINARILY
UNCERTAIN DAN WILL DEPEND IN
LARGE PART ON OUR SUCCESS IN
CONTAINING THE VIRUS.
A FULL RECOVERY IS UNLIKELY TO
OCCUR UNTIL PEOPLE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT IT’S SAFE TO ENGAGE IN A
BROAD RANGE OF ACTIVITIES.
>> THE VIRUS WIPED OUT TAX
SEASON IN APRIL, THE NEW
DEADLINE IS JULY 15TH.